how you guys doing
hi steve how are you good to see you
nice to see both of you
um uh first of all congrats on the movie
um
uh a lot to talk about with that but
during the pandemic i've been asking
everyone the same two first questions
uh and so here we go what tv series
would each of you like to guest star on
uh oh my god there's so many um
well okay realistically great british
bake off
i think you know that could actually
happen you know
um but um
[Music]
i don't know i mean i i feel like
stranger things they just
seem like they're having so much fun
like i i love like kids on an adventure
stuff that i love that stuff
for me uh succession i'm a huge fan of
that show
um would love to be a part of that and
and ted lasso because that has been
getting me through
this pandemic i mean just thank god for
ted lasso
uh what movie or movies do you think
you've seen the most
uh the women i've seen so many times
that i i i got to
introduce it uh turner classic movies uh
asked me to introduce a screening of it
at um the egyptian or
i don't know it was anyway um and it was
so bizarre
watching it with a crowd because i'd
seen it by myself and with my family
so many times and with like my childhood
best friends and high school best
friends because i made them watch it
with me
um that it was bizarre it was it felt
like i was in a dream
or like that people were watching a
dream i had like to experience an
audience watching this movie that i just
know
backwards and forwards um was a really
unique experience
i've been watching a lot of like academy
nominated movies these days just because
i want to catch up and see
you know what everyone's talking about
and uh i gotta say i really love minari
and uh and i watched judas and the black
messiah and the trial of the chicago
seven i watched them back to back
and i thought it was a really it was
really fascinating that we were
that you had the same character in both
movies and it was
just a really great way to examine our
history and so those were
those are three memorable movies just uh
in the recent past
jumping into why i get to talk to you
guys today one of the things that i
thought was really cool
about this movie is that there's no
villain trying to get you guys
it's it's uh you guys are just in a bad
situation
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of the script
yeah i mean early on you know the four
of us because you know there's only four
of us in the cast we would
sort of talk about the dynamics in the
movie and
at one point i remember somebody i think
there was like a
somebody who did a set visit a
journalist who did a set visit where he
didn't know
the script and he was like well you seem
like the strongest one so you could
probably overpower these three and we
were like oh it's not that kind of movie
you know like i love that the movie
doesn't
like devolve into us trying to
get each other and trick each other like
that all of us have this goal of
how do we survive this how do we get
through this together
um because i think those are the those
are the most interesting um
problems where you really sort of show
your uh
you know your character you know your
integrity is when like
i can't just turn on someone and get
angry and blame them we're just in a
terrible situation together
and obviously like the last year we have
all been in a very terrible situation
together
and everybody really wants a scapegoat
but it's a lot harder to
just go like okay this is nobody's fault
and we just need to
come together and pool our resources and
make sacrifices so that we can all
get through this with the best outcomes
that we can it's a lot more like real
life when you're
reading a script like this and you're
just told that it's you know
something set in space uh i was i
remember reading the first act and going
like oh wait they're low on oxygen
is this going to be a creature feature
is this gonna be like there's something
on our ship
uh and oh and then you find out that
it's not and then you
then you ask well is this person gonna
try and murder everyone and so they're
you know they're all the tropes that
your mind goes through as you read a
script
and it was really refreshing to see that
it wasn't about any of those things
it was about man versus nature there was
no villain it was just
all thoughtfully fleshed out characters
do you guys
think that the crew makes it to mars
i think some of the crew makes it to
mars yes exactly
how do you define crew well i'm trying
i'm trying to say it
you know without saying i'm just i'm
wondering if you guys think that the
crew makes it to mars
yeah i assumed yeah i think thanks to
the actions
of you know of some of our crew the rest
of the crew will make it
got it uh and then the other thing is um
there is a really
nail-biting spacewalk that takes place
in this movie
where uh i'm just curious if you could
talk a little bit about filming that
thing
and then the reaction to seeing the
edited footage
i'm so glad that uh something was
reading on my face other than just
misery oh actually though you know what
i mean yes
obviously like we daniel and i have been
talking about how like
it's a very uncomfortable uh filming
situation to be in a space suit and
climbing these tethers because you know
we think there might be oxygen on the
other end of this craft that we have to
you know do this spacewalk
um but i remember there was
only one piece of footage when we first
started filming the stuff in the suits
um that joe our director showed to me
and daniel
that we had to redo for some reason you
wanted a different camera angle
and he showed it to me and i i genuinely
did
we talked about this i have that feeling
of like oh
you're really only seeing like th this
you know like even like uh things that
you
totally take for granted as a performer
that like you know the tightness in your
jaw and the you know the angle of your
uh of your body language like
that i thought would read it's like oh
all of that gets lost so i have to just
be thinking about
like eyes nose lips that's it because
i thought i was like you know conveying
uh my uh my emotions and what's at stake
and everything like through
my performance and then you realize like
oh so little of it is on screen and you
forget like how much you rely on
uh your body language and you know your
neck and your jaw and stuff and
yeah to just be limited to this much of
your face was
challenging thankfully we had great
stunt people who helped us out as well
and the the final footage was
so much more sophisticated than what i
thought it was going to be based on what
i was trying to do
you know in those scenes because you
know we were focused on
just trying to climb properly and and
not fall down
yeah it's definitely a nail-biting
sequence on that note i gotta go
just gonna say congrats hope you guys
stay safe and uh be well
thank you